Matt I am rocking my Soca buff for you
today because it was a crazy episode and
an emotional send-off we have so many
like twists and turns and even papayas
to talk about so we have to jump right
into it right so now that the episode is
aired and everything is out there how
are you feeling today
yeah I'm feeling great honestly
um
uh this was a desperate time for me
um and maybe if you're like really Keen
you can pick up on that in the tribal
and in my
I was so desperate and grasping at
straws and they they could have painted
a picture of like a man gone insane like
this kooky lunatic um and it was this
beautiful like swan song emotional
send-off so I I mean I I cherish that
actually like I think that that's really
really special and I'm you know in the
moment it was hard to watch really hard
to watch I was weeping um but after
having like kind of let that uh process
I I feel really good about how this all
went down I thought it was beautiful and
like really sweet so no it was beautiful
and it was powerful and like I'm so glad
that you're able to kind of be on this
side now and enjoy the journey of it all
and watch it back and but now we have to
go back to the beginning of the episode
first and talk about that because not
only did you not have two votes at
Tribal Council because of your journey
early in the season but then at the
beginning of the episode talking to
Brandon and he tells you and makes you
believe that you now have a fake Idol
which was true but
um because of what happened at the bird
cage on ratsu but what was going through
your mind when he was having that
conversation with you it was like
another blow yeah so honestly
um they didn't show this but I was
already suspicious of this Idol like I
was like pretty
sure that it was fake uh or at least not
yeah there was something fishy with it
um and I didn't know who had the real
Soca Idol
um but I had heard that ratsu had two
Idols in their cage and I had only found
one so you know like it doesn't take a
genius to like put these things together
um that was the moment though like after
the Josh vote was when I was sure it was
Danny
um because and this factored into the
Josh vote as well like I he Josh was
telling everyone all sorts of crazy
stories about his Idol situation and I
was like maybe he has it you know like
he and Danny had gone off by themselves
quite a lot at Soca so
um and then when he didn't play it was I
was like this is definitely
um Danny but it does feel like
everything that could go wrong for me in
this game went wrong from a production
standpoint right like I lost two votes I
got this fake Idol I get screwed over by
the rock draw like everything that could
have gone wrong went wrong and you know
like sometimes that's how it just shakes
out um but you were still so positive
throughout it all right like you were
still having that positive energy and
that that bringing that to the camp and
like it's so interesting because you're
right like all this new information kind
of comes out when you hit the merge
right usually you are come making new
relationships or new alliances and we
saw that from you but we still also kept
coming back to you and Franny and they
even showed us like they showed us that
you were sneaking away while they were
naming the merge tribe are they pissed
you guys being together
um but were you expecting to have to
find such a strong relationship in the
game coming into it oh absolutely not
and and I cannot tell you the number of
times we're like we can't be talking to
each other like this is terrible for a
game you know like it's Survivor 101 you
don't get into a show man it's like
that's immediately a Target
um but you know we couldn't help it I
mean the chemistry is like immediate and
apparent to everyone involved like it
was not subtle and um we did to be fair
I think we toned down the like Matt and
Franny one-on-one like
um cutesy time as as the show went on we
knew we had to like play our own games
um and I think you know like this last
episode
um all of like we were not spending that
much time together I swear it looks dumb
but you know we we're playing the game
we both know it like it's not a good
luck
um but at the same time you know
it's undeniable worse like we couldn't
separate and um you know we still can't
separate well that was my next question
mystery we saw the Montage I have to ask
like are you still together is there
something there there is something huge
there we are going strong like uh you
know Manny Stanis rise up like we're
we're crushing the game right now
um yeah like me and Franny still dating
we're still together
um we did go get Ethiopian food
um road chip on the cards we're making
it happen so you know you have to come
to Toronto next that's the next road
trip oh I'd love to
that's awesome no well it's like it's so
awesome to see that chemistry and I'm so
glad like where everyone had to be a fan
of that like you could not be right so
like speaking of the two of you though
like there was more drama than that
happening this this uh episode because
at the immunity challenge Jeff announces
this new twist where they are splitting
the tribe into two teams and you're
competing for group safety and you and
Franny end up on opposite teams
were were you like what were you
thinking when you looked at the people
around you on the purple tribe like
right as you drew the rock like what was
racing through your mind at that moment
it was so so bad for me
um I felt and I said this at the
beginning of the episode and I stand by
this my I was playing a pretty good
social game in The Wider group of 11
people I felt very strong actually like
confident in my position but everyone I
have a relationship is on the other side
like everyone and I was like oh
like this could not have gone worse for
me like literally any other group of
five names uh would have been I think
better for me than this particular one
and so yeah like right from the off look
at yeah looking at the Rocks I'm like
wow this is this is bad for me like this
is bad news
um yeah and the the the like ocean
feelings were already there um before we
even started the challenge right well
and then the challenge came down to
Franny versus Brandon and she became
immune as the orange team member the
last one standing was a like when you
left Tribal Council you said to her like
you were proud of her for winning but
was there a little part of you during
the challenge or hoping she would drop
so that you both would be safe yeah
there's a little obviously I mean so
they didn't show this but the challenge
is long it was like an hour of standing
on that pole
so you have a lot of time to crunch
numbers right
um and you know I'm of course I'm
thinking like for any drop the freaking
thing like yeah like we're we're safe
you and I are safe like you can figure
it out on that side and we'll come back
together this is good we can work with
this
um but at the same time right like I
truly like genuinely am super proud of
Franny right we all survivor it's it's
like this dream for all of us and like
you know the fantasy of Jeff being like
here's the immunity necklace like I mean
we all have had that we love that yeah I
have it of course take that away from
Franny like I think that that was like a
huge a huge moment for her I mean she
broke down in tears like I cried
watching that as well like I it was so
powerful that like and even honestly in
the moment I was like you know the scene
of like the little girl from Minnesota
versus the giant like Goliath man who
played in the NFL and then like she
comes out on top like you can't help but
love that right uh like that's that's
pure poetry so I you know I am very
proud of her do I wish she dropped the
ball probably but you know also it's
fine and I and it you know I
I I never fault her for it um not once
right well it's the adrenal of it all
too right like you're in the moment
you're not thinking about all the
different possibilities so you have to
understand but it's it's definitely hard
I'm sure
um so then after the challenge you go
back to the old Soca Beach and you and
jam Jam obviously felt like you were
fighting for your lives in the game did
you feel like you were throwing out
Lauren's name you're throwing out
different names trying anything did you
feel at all that you were convincing the
Roxy majority of anything or was it
really just the balls in their Court the
whole time and you just go with it yeah
I was I you know like I tried I I
arrived at the beach with hope I'm an
optimistic guy but after talking with
all of them it was so abundantly clear
that they were never gonna swing
um and I was actually pretty sure it was
me and I think you can see this in my
confessionals and in tribal like for me
it was unambiguous and
um I I tried my best like they were they
were very kind to me in the edit like I
was flailing it's truly I was throwing
everything I could at the wall and you
know in a different world they could
have painted me as like this lunatic
just like spouting nonsense
um and they didn't and I'm like very
thankful for that but like uh yeah it
was not I was I it was very clearly
going to be me that night right well
then when Heidi stood up at tribal
though and played her control the vote
advantage and stole Lauren's vote to
cast on Jam Jam like what what were you
feeling then because you must have been
like what is going on yeah such a crazy
emotional way Whiplash uh because I'm
like at my lowest of lows right like
scraping myself off of the floor and
then Heidi stands up and she's like I've
got this advantage and I immediately I'm
like she can save me like when she just
explained it I knew and she didn't know
this but I knew that me and jam Jam
would vote together
um if any ratsu was on any other ratu um
and like that was immediately apparent
for me I was like I'm saved and then she
says Lauren on Jam jam and I'm like no
like that's the one one thing that you
can't do like that screws me
um you know like that changes nothing
it's a it's like a non
uh issue it doesn't affect the vote in
any way and so I was kind of like you
know the Whiplash of going from I'm
screwed oh I'm saved actually I'm still
screwed like oh God it was tumultuous to
say the least oh my God I'm sure I can't
I can't imagine sitting there and having
like the chaos around you happening and
you're like what is what is happening
yeah literally after bearing my soul
well that's my next question because
like it went from like one of the most
hilarious moments to one of the most
emotional moments of the episode while
you were trying to bribe the mighty
probes with a papaya to cancel the vote
like I'm just like please tell me more
like how did that come to be like what
were you thinking with that you know
that was like a off the cuff spur of the
moment choice I was like I kind of
thought if I'm gonna go I'm gonna go
like laughing you know I want to make
this fun I want to make it entertaining
um and I you know I have this papaya
which I didn't it wasn't a plan I was
literally just bringing that to the
other group because I thought they'd be
hungry
um and like I was just like what if I
offer this you know like maybe this is
literally like all I have and I'm gonna
throw all I have at it like because why
not and so yeah it was it was funny
um but then Jeff turns it around he says
like if if this is your last vote you
know like what how does that make you
feel like what do you think about the
the game and that broke me like I really
I you know that was the moment when I
felt like it really all came crashing
down and so it was like yeah I mean the
tonal Whiplash was well reflected and
like it really was like that in tribal
as well like I was playing like just
being funny and making jokes and smiling
and then just you know all the way into
this other space yeah no it was so much
well that's my next question because you
have this powerful moment talking about
the anxiety you were bringing with you
into the game and now you become the
first jury member of the season and
you've watched your experience back I'm
wondering now that you've had this time
to reflect what do you feel your biggest
person personal accomplishment was or
take away from playing Survivor yeah I
mean so this is a massive growth Journey
for me um in terms of just like
self-confidence and like believing in my
own voice and like what I have to bring
to the table
um I I think I went into this game kind
of like oh like you know I got here by
mistake like a little me is showing up
on this beach and like you know you
compare yourself to people like Danny or
Carolyn or Jam Jam like they're so
charismatic they're so themselves
they're so confident and I was like like
I don't belong here at all and then you
know
watching myself back and like seeing
myself play these things out and also
like just you know being inspired by
these people who I'm meeting I was kind
of like wow like maybe I can just like
be myself and let that person out and
like have that kind of play out and so
now I feel like I believe in my own
voice so much more I'm not questioning
everything I say you should have seen me
in the first couple interviews I was
tripping over every word like
overthinking everything like I could
barely get a sentence out and now you
know like look at me now yeah so I feel
I mean it's been a huge uh personal
growth for me just to Devout like you
know tell myself that I have a voice and
that voice matters and
um like it's worth bringing out into the
world
um yeah absolutely well thank you so
much like it really did translate on
screen as well your openness and being
so fun with who you were or they're out
on the game with and being vulnerable
and bringing your whole self to the game
you're obviously a huge fan like myself
and like it was so cool to watch that on
screen so thank you so much for talking
with me it was a pleasure watching you
play watching you play this game and
living out this stream and I can't wait
to see how the rest of the season turns
out thank you so much it's great great
job thank you of course thank you
shh